- ♪ Et peine à Dieu, ma mère
Adieu, tous mes parents
Voilà que je vous quitte
Aujourd'hui pour longtemps ♪
- Cette chanson, Jean Lapointe
l'avait lui-même chantée dans
l'un de ses rôles au cinéma.
- ♪ D'avoir eu peur d'la mort ♪
JEAN-MARIE LAPOINTE,
fils de Jean Lapointe
- C'est le plus bel hommage
à papa que tu pou p p pas faire.
(applaudissements)
- Un hommage émotif
pour son père, mais aussi
l'auteur, le chanteur,
le comédien, l'humoriste.
FRANÇOIS LEGAULT,
premier ministre du Québec
- Jean Lapointe savait comment
toucher le coeur des Québécois.
JEAN CHRÉTIEN, premier ministre
du Canada (1993-2003)
- Jean Lapointe fut un des
grands francs s s s du Québec
et du Canada de sa génération.
- Un homme plus grand que nature
qui a inspiré des milliers
d'artistes.
BENOÎT BRIÈRE, comédien
- Son jeu naturaliste, son jeu
vrai, ancré totalement dans
la vérité, il est de l'ordre du
documentaire. On n'avait jamais
vu ça au cinema québécois,
on n'avait jamais vu ça
à la télévision québécoise.
LOUISE LATRAVERSE, comédienne,
auteure, metteuse en scène
- C'est une grande sensibilité,
de comprendre et de pouvoir
exprimer les émotions de la
condition humaine, et c'était
ce talent-là qu'il avait.
CLAUDE MEUNIER, acteur,
dramaturge, humoriste
- C'est un grand imitateur,
c'est un grand chanteur,
c'est un compositeur...
t t t t t vraiment la quintessee
de l'artiste. C'était un grand,
grand artiste, puis je l'ai
connu dans la vie, aussi.
C'était quelqu'un de spécial,
Jean Lapointe. Un genre
de Duplessis des arts.
RODRIGUE PARÉ, directeur émérite
Maison Jean Lapointe
- Pour nous, Jean Lapointe
était souvent un emmerdeur
de la pire espèce.
- C'est avec humour
que celui qui a dirigé
la Maison Jean Lapointe a décrit
la générosité du fondateur :
Jean Lapointe le résilient,
le combattant de l'alcoolisme.
- Tu t'es servi de tes
souffrances pour alléger celles
de tes soeurs et frères d'armes.
40 années de don de soi, à ce
que tu appelles à juste titre
ta plus grande fierté :
ta Fondation et ta Maison
Jean Lapointe.
- Un modèle pour tant
dedededededede l'alcool.
ROBERT PICHÉ,
ancien pilote et conférencier
- C'est notre guide, hein.
ntntntntntntntré le chemin
vers l'abstinence.
- ♪ Ils sont assez
à la chanter ♪
- Jean Lapointe, un des piliers,
s'est éteint en emportant les
souvenirs d'une génération de
Québécois, ne laissant que ses
oeuvres à l'épreuve du temps. Iu
Radio-Canada, Montréal.
- ♪ Ils sont assez
à raconter
La même histoire
Où tout est gris
ou tout est noir